[ __ ]
do you remember me your mom's name is
Sara he used to wear newspapers in your
shoes you're a wanted man I don't do
that anymore
well the people who think you did are
coming right now they're not planning on
taking you alive
captain while a great many people see
you as a hero there are some who'd
prefer the word vigilante they've
operated with unlimited power and no
supervision that's something the world
can no longer tolerate
I never much Bucky is you stay out of
this one
please you only make us worse you saying
you'll arrest me
big consequences captain you seem a
little defensive buzz been a long day if
you can't accept limitations we're no
better than bad guys that's not the way
I see
sometimes I want to punch you in your
perfect teeth
I just want to make sure we consider all
our options just people that shoot at
you usually wind up shooting at me - you
know what's about to happen
do you really want to punch your way out
of this
what do we do to fight
sorry Tommy you know I wouldn't do this
if I had any other choice but he's my
friend
so was I